republicanos y demócratas tienen unos
días más para ponerse de acuerdo antes
que Estados Unidos caiga un
incumplimiento de su deuda la secretaria
del tesoro Janet yelen aplazó la fecha
límite de este posible escenario de
impago antes se estimaba que el primero
de junio del Gobierno Federal se
quedaría sin fondos para pagar sus
facturas ahora esta fecha se mueve hasta
el 5 de junio ya hemos visto que los
costos de endeudamiento del tesoro
aumentan sustancialmente para los
valores que vencen a principios de junio
ahora estimamos que el tesoro tendrá
recursos insuficientes para cumplir con
las obligaciones del gobierno si el
congreso no eleva o suspende el límite
de la deuda antes del 5 de junio lo
republicanos han exigido recortes en el
gasto público algo que los demócratas
catalogaron inicialmente como
innegociable Pues con ese dinero la
administración biden planea un
despliegue de programas sociales para
los estadounidenses sin embargo con el
reloj en contra ya se habla de que el
techo de la deuda se podría aplazar
hasta 2025 siempre y cuando haya un
posible recorte presupuestario de dos
años previo al anuncio del departamento
del tesoro byden se mostró optimista
sobre las negociaciones
con respecto al límite de la deuda las
cosas se ven bien muy optimistas Espero
que tengamos alguna evidencia más clara
esta noche antes que el reloj de las 12
de que tenemos un trato Pero está muy
cerca y soy optimista
y es que la también llamada fecha x es
un escenario en el que ya se habrán
agotado las medidas extraordinarias que
desplegó el tesoro luego de que el país
haya superado el límite de endeudamiento
de 31,4 billones de dólares